[Music]  i will ask you simple questions you will  answer in short sentences only what you  believe to be absolute truth absolute  truth  i can do that  now  brief as you can  what is your name  stanton carlisle  are you a true medium yes i am  mr carla  doctor how about that  please lie down  can you read minds yes i can under the  right circumstances  keep the answers brief  what do i want to be found out same as  everybody else  are you in contact with the beyond  well we've had our share of snake  charmers in the past  we deal with them  [Music]  you know people stand  they fool themselves  i've given you a fortune it's time that  you delivered  when does it end  i want to know  if you displease the right people the  world closes in on you very very fast  [Music]  [Music]  you